so you're a Proctor and Gamble in the
mid-1800s you've been making a decent
living selling candles and soap made
from animal fat for a few decades now
but come 1870 and things are getting
tough there's an economic downturn and
you really really don't want to end up
on the streets like these Schmucks
so you quickly swap out the animal fat
in your soaps for a cheaper alternative
coconut and palm oil you call your new
creation Ivory soap
you Market it as a pure alternative to
all those nasty fat based soaps your
competitors are manufacturing and people
love it Ivory so it becomes the number
one soap used by hundreds of thousands
of people all around the world and since
you're manufacturing it from cheap
coconut and palm oil you're making more
money than ever before but then you
start thinking
we saved a ton of money switching from
expensive animal fat to cheap coconut
and palm oil but what if there was an
even cheaper oil we can use in our soap
even cheaper oil equals more profits so
you start experimenting with cottonseed
oil what is cottonseed oil you may ask
why haven't you heard about it before
that's because cottonseed oil was only
used as an industrial oil for
lubricating machines and stuff and it's
highly toxic causing things like
infertility pregnancy problems liver
damage respiratory problems and loss of
appetite but whatever let's just work
with it all you have to do is find a way
to remove the toxin gossipole from the
oil figure out how to turn this
permanently liquid oil into a solid and
you will be golden compared to coconut
oil conceit oil was Dirt Cheap so you
hire a chemist named Edwin Kaiser to try
to figure out a way to get around that
little toxicity issue with cottonseed
oil and boom Edwin Kaiser pulls through
he comes up with a chemical process
called hydrogenation and successfully
turns his highly toxic liquid oil into
solid gold you can see it now your
cottonseed oil Innovation would change
the world of toiletries forever but but
not all as you sat back and took in the
Glorious bar of solid oil sitting in
front of you something hits you see
unlike today where pretty much every
single family cooks with vegetable oils
in their kitchen back then every
housewife cooked with real animal fats
they come with animal fat in the form of
lard lard that was very pricey so you
thought to yourself wait a minute
doesn't this solid form of cottonseed
oil kind of remind you of lard why don't
we also Market it as a cheaper
alternative to lard people will love it
and so Crisco was born really Chris not
greasy sure the crisp goes in the french
fries because Crisco oil stays in the
pan all the oil almost watch I'll
measure the Crisco oil then fry these
potatoes and oh Crisco oil stays in the
pan and you poured everything you had
into a massive marketing campaign a
marketing campaign to inculcate the
masses into switching from natural
animal fat to this industrial food
product that started out as toxic Crisco
was new it was fresh it was so much
cheaper than buying real nasty animal
fats I mean come on what sounds better
to you nasty fatty animal lard or Crisco
there was simply no competition So
within just a few years America became
hooked on Crisco but then you thought to
yourself why just stop at cottonseed oil
there are so many other seed oils out
there so throughout the years this same
hydrogenation process used to turn
cottonseed oil into a solid would also
be used to create soybean oil corn oil
canola oil grapeseed oil and many other
industrial aceto amine vegetable oils
there that has a nice healthy ring to it
you know I always wonder about what PR
room came up with the word vegetable oil
they're not made from vegetable oils
vegetables like broccoli or anything
they're made from seeds and beans so
grapeseed oil like any of these grain
and Seed oils like corn oil canola oil
which comes from the rapeseed plants
soybean oil they're referred to
sometimes within the food industry as
RBD oils refined bleached and deodorized
oil yeah because they're they have like
these like again these harsh bitter Flav
flavor is Right some of them like like
the rapeseed contain toxins like urusic
acid they might want to change the name
of that seed yeah right doesn't it seem
like a rude way you know you want a
murder fruit no you know what I'm saying
yeah like why is it rape seed exactly
and it works by 1980 almost every
restaurant in the U.S switched over to
using these cheaper seed oils in their
fryers and by 1993 Americans were
consuming an average of 30 grams of seed
oils per day compared to Just 2 grams in
1909 and for you as Procter and Gamble
life couldn't be better you were making
millions but then something happened
that would turn your fairy tale into a
nightmare the study started coming out
studies showing that polysaturated fat
found in vegetable oils turns into a
varnish-like substance in the intestines
like this kind of varnish that vegetable
oil is linked to high rates of cancer
Alzheimer's disease and heart disease
and because these oils are not natural
like their names want you to think they
get stored deep in our tissues and brain
so everyone's walking around with old
talks of oil in their bodies slowly
inching them towards disease these fats
also integrate themselves into your body
you are what you eat right and this is
especially true for the kinds of fats
that we consume any polyunsaturated fat
You Give a Pig is ending up in its fat
any polyun texture to fat that you or I
eat is ending up in our fat tissue this
is how much natural fats from things
like beef pork Dairy have been in our
diet since 1960 this line is for
vegetable oils and this line is the
Obesity rates
Procter and Gamble fooled us all Trotter
and Gamble and all these other companies
fooled us into throwing away perfectly
fine natural fats that came from real
animals in exchange for these food
products food products that started out
as toxic Industrial Waste and yet we
willingly take the bite every single day
Popular Science wrote what was garbage
in 1860 was fertilizer in 1870 cattle
feed in 1880 and table food and many
things else in 1890 End quotes but today
today industrial seed oils are found
everywhere from fast food to restaurant
kitchens to cookies crackers chips candy
vegetable Puffs granola bars and even
nut milks you and your family probably
have some in your pantry right now the
seed oil industry oiled up America they
oiled up the world and they're raking in
a quarter of a trillion dollars every
year from it at your expense stay
dangerous subscribe for more and this is
the evil business of seed oils
Chris Goyle wouldn't let me down it's
nice to know you can trust Crisco oil to
fry chicken that doesn't taste greasy
today I try my best to cut out all seed
oils for my diet and something I've also
started obsessing over is longevity
living longer healthier and reversing
aging and the great news is that
longevity research has exploded over the
past few years and researchers have
actually found real supplements that you
can take that have been shown to
decrease aging if you follow people like
Dr David Sinclair you know that he takes
something called nmn and Resveratrol
that's because taking these two things
increases something called NAD Plus in
your body NAD plus is insanely important
for your longevity because it helps with
things like DNA repair energy metabolism
and mitochondrial function so you
definitely want to supplement it I was
ready to buy some but the problem was I
didn't know what brand to trust because
the supplement industry is super super
sketchy sure you can pick some up on
Amazon but how do you know how much
actual nmn is in there or if it's been
tested for toxic metals or if it was
made in China That's why when I found
out about Verso from the concrete
podcast big fan I bought someone with my
own money on the spots and I've been
taking their cell being supplement every
day since all you got to do is take two
of these capsules every day
and boom you got your daily dose of nmn
Resveratrol and something called TMG but
what I really love about Verso is that
their products are made in California
they perform third-party testing on
every batch that you can check on their
website they store their stuff in coach
stores so the molecules don't degrade
and they come to this cute packaging I
am a sucker for good product design I am
telling you guys it doesn't matter how
much money or power you have if your
house sucks that's why you gotta pick up
some self being at ver.so Jake Tran with
code Jake Tran for 15 off your order
that's ver.so Jake Tran will code jtran
for 50 off with the link below thanks to
Verso for sponsoring this video are you
sure this is gonna work why not I made a
Crisco pie yeah me too but a cake I
think you should have waited till your
wife gets back Crisco first hit grocery
shelves in 1911 and going in your
marketing teams knew they couldn't just
let the ingredients speak for themselves
you had to convince the American public
that eating a chemically solidified slab
of cottonseed oil that previously could
have rented you in Fertile was not only
normal but better for you you had to
convince the public that it was even
better than butter so to achieve this
monstrous feat you are gonna have to
launch one of the most epic advertising
campaigns in American history to do that
you hired Jay Walter Thompson a
legendary full-service Ad Agency created
by the American advertising Pioneer by
the same name J Walter Thompson was
actually the very first full-service Ad
Agency in America as well and they got
to work right away they mailed samples
of criscoll to restaurants and grocery
stores they handed out Crisco fried
donuts in the streets they give away
free Crisco cookbooks with every
purchase which all sound like standard
marketing tactics today but back then it
was nothing short of revolutionary you
tell the writers at the age to say
Crisco is digestible although you had no
scientific proof of this it sure does
sound good and you also make sure that
no one ever mentions the word cottonseed
because that would just remind people of
self-detergent and Machinery lubricant
and not something that you would want to
consume the only thing on the
ingredients list is a hundred percent
shortening and if anyone ever asks you
what shortening is you say it's made
from vegetables in reality cottonseed is
a seed but sure I guess you could
technically call it a vegetable if you
really wanted to it grows on complaints
doesn't it and vegetables also grow on
Plants so it's basically the same thing
and all of this mislabeling and
misinformation was happening at the
perfect time in history because detailed
food labeling loss from the FDA wouldn't
be mandated until the late 60s So for 50
sweet years you could say Crisco was
whatever you wanted it to be
makes my process flaky is all good ass
cause I get out my Crisco and I do some
special bacon
I love trying out no recipe
cookies
or flavor Crisco is
and within just a few short years Crisco
officially became the American Baker's
best friend but why stop there why not
use all your Crisco expertise to expand
your product line even more
[Music]
Betsy
oil after World War II Proctor and
Gamble started experimenting with
partial hydrogenation so instead of
turning cottonseed oil into a solid they
just kind of stopped halfway leaving it
as a liquid while still removing all the
toxic chemicals color and bad smells
this partially hydrogenated oil could be
kept on the shelf for years unlike
disgusting animal fat restaurants love
that because they didn't have to keep
changing the oil in their fryers they
could just keep reusing it it just never
went bad what a miracle right Nabisco
and craft love that because their
cookies could stay on Warehouse shelves
for months and months and months and
still be crunchy and during this new era
of hydrogenated oils Proctor and Gamble
ditched the rancid cotton seed oil that
they collected from cotton farms for an
even cheaper alternative the leftover
rinses soybean oil from animal feed
production so we went from using real
animal fat to coconut and palm oil to
cottonseed oil to Now using a waste
product from animal feed production you
know the stuff that isn't even fit for
animals to consume
that sounds yummy so now Crisco products
no longer contain cottonseed oil no
that's far too luxurious for the masses
now Crisco only contains soybean oil and
your Empire only continued to grow
[Music]
today's Crisco oil is remarkably clear
remarkably light so you taste your fish
not our oil and there's no cholesterol
but then just like crisco's lard
alternative scientists started telling
the world just how bad these
hydrogenated oils were for your body and
so the War Began
boom gets new Crisco oil you're gonna
love eating light baby you're the one
you're the one with the healthy in my
healthy appetite with all this talk of
vegetable oils being the New Frontier
scientists All Over America started
getting suspicious how can an oil this
process be good for you and if it was
why didn't we think of it first so they
headed for the labs and what they found
was not flattering for you one group of
scientists found that although replacing
animal fats with vegetable oils did
lower cholesterol by 13 it also made you
twice as likely to die from cancer
another group replaced animal fats with
vegetable oils in the diets of men who
had a history of heart disease and
discovered that the ones who ate
vegetable oil had a higher chance of
dying this wasn't exactly music to your
ears but you also weren't too worried
about a few nerds in the lab because
even though scientists were telling the
world how bad vegetable oils were for
your health you had already formed a
secret alliance with the one
organization that mattered most the
American Heart Association or aha if you
took all the cigarettes in the world and
laid them end to end you would never had
time to smoke a single foreign
[Music]
in the 40s and 50s the American Heart
Association wasn't the huge non-profit
it is today back then heart disease in
the American Heart Association wasn't
exactly a big deal to most Americans but
you knew something was coming you knew
the truth about your cheap oils would
eventually be revealed so you went on
the offensive in 1949 you chose the
American Heart Association to receive a
1.5 million dollar prize from a national
radio competition that you happen to be
the sponsor of 1.5 million dollars in
1949 would be the equivalent of 19
million dollars today a huge paycheck
for a relatively unknown organization
like the AHA generous right and it
helped them go National overnight the
AHA now had all the power and resources
it would ever need to influence the
masses what the Russian would have
influenced the masses in well these
scientists are humans at the end of the
day humans that would like to maintain
their prestigious titles and positions
if possible so if the AHA wanted daddy's
money to keep rolling in it would be in
their best interest to maybe not bad now
vegetable oils it would maybe be in
their best interest to paint vegetable
oils in the best light possible and then
they of course as we know they got a
huge boost when the American Heart
Association started recommending
polyunsaturated vegetable oils to
replace saturated fats and this was a
tremendous boost to the vegetable oil
industry so thanks to your new
propaganda arm you the seed oil industry
finally had free rain to Market your
oils as good for your heart and overall
health so you went around advertising
all the upsets of the scientific studies
we've mentioned earlier that seed oils
lowered cholesterol by 13 that they're
way healthier than butter that they're
so clear and white there's no way you
could doubt their purity gets new Crisco
oil you're gonna love eating light but
that wasn't all because in 1961 a study
would be released by the AHA that would
forever change the way Americans thought
about vegetable oil the study was done
by a famous physiologist named Ansel
keys and it said that animal fats like
butter actually raised cholesterol and
high cholesterol causes heart attacks
his solution replace your thick
disgusting animal fat with vegetable
oils because of their proven ability to
lower cholesterol by 13 and the world
ate it up and with that the seed oil
industry had achieved something
staggering what was garbage in 1860 was
fertilizer in 1870 cattle feed in 1880
table food and many things else in 1890
and now what's the hottest new health
food in 1961 and oh have we paid the
price
[Music]
here's Crisco cooking up fries and
because most of it comes back there's no
oily taste
the process of hydrogenation major
vegetable oils edible but there was a
caveats see during the hydrogenation
process a new type of fat is created
trans fats you could call this fat
man-made frankenfat in general trans fat
is considered the worst fat anyone could
eat because it's not from nature it's an
artificial fat that's produced through
the hydrogenation process these
polyunsaturated saturated fats as I
mentioned the oils that that are rich in
them have trans fats which we know are
not friendly to your cardiovascular
system they're not friendly to your
brain higher consumption of trans fats
is associated with higher risk for
developing Alzheimer's disease and worse
memory function even in the young and
healthy
potential is that every single day all
of us in the western world if we're
eating excess vegetable oils excess
polyunsaturated fats specifically
linoleic acid we are driving a signal to
our adipocytes that winter is coming get
fat stay fat whoa and by the 1980s all
those pesky scientists that keep trying
to debunk your healthy oil claims we're
getting really concerned about these
artificial trans fats in 1990 two Dutch
scientists released a study revealing
that artificial trans fats actually
raise your cholesterol even more than
animal fats do causing a huge risk for
coronary heart disease this was not what
you and your other vegetable oil Giants
wanted to hear so you tried to fight
science with science in 1994 a group of
edible oil manufacturers funded Joseph
Judd a scientist from the U.S department
of Agriculture to try to prove that
trans fats didn't cause heart disease
but it didn't work Joseph ended up with
the same results as a Dutch scientist
and this finally caused the FDA to
finally pressure the seed oil industry
to at least label how much trans fats
are in your products as simple as the
request seemed you really didn't want to
do it why because your Crisco shortening
contains 50 trans fat and according to
the studies if just two percent of your
daily fat intake comes from trans fat
your risk of heart disease goes up by 23
people were basically spreading heart
attack on their morning toast the fda's
decision to make trans fat information
public could end June so what did you do
you reformulated you went to none other
than Monsanto the company behind agent
orange GMOs seed licensing which
practically makes them the company that
owns the world's food supply watch our
private documentary on Monsanto by
clicking that join button below and you
asked Monsanto to create a genetically
modified soybean that doesn't produce
artificial trans fats in the
hydrogenation process what did anyone
really think you were going to learn
from your mistakes and go back to a
healthier more expensive oil Source
don't be silly thanks to monsanto's GMO
genius you got what you wanted now all
your packages sported a big red stamp
saying zero trans fat so everyone knew
you were the good guy now the guy
looking out for everyone's Health but
there's just one last secret one last
loophole you use to Rebrand into a
health-conscious alternative fat brand
see when the FDA announced in 2003 that
you guys had to put trans fat content on
your labels you were actually still
allowed to say zero trans fat as long as
the product didn't have more than 0.5
grams per serving according to the fda's
rules the key word here is per serving
so if one tablespoon of Crisco has 12
grams of fats and 0.5 grams of that is
artificial trans fat then 8.3 percent of
the fat content is trans fat
and a study said if two percent of the
fat you eat is trans fat it could cost a
23 increase in heart disease I know I
know I know it's enough to make an oil
tycoon's head spin but this still wasn't
the end you needed to ride the zero
grams of trans fat way for as long as
possible before your time finally ran
out
[Music]
today we're going to talk about
eliminating toxic seed oils and
margarine is terrible for you vegetable
oil yeah and now people know what's
really good for you is grass-fed butter
the grass-fed butter is actually not bad
for you at all the more I dig into it
the more I believe this is the center of
human chronic health issues the year is
2015 and the FDA has officially banned
artificial trans fats from All Foods
giving everyone until 2018 to get them
completely out of their products except
the 0.5 grams per serving because we all
need a little wiggle room this is why
you'll still see Crisco sitting on
grocery store shelves with 0.5 grams of
fat missing from the nutrition label and
even though shortening is way less
popular than it was in the 60s and 70s
is still available to buy people are
still using it in online cooking videos
certainly high fructose corn to syrup is
not helping anything but I think it's
important for people to understand that
that might not be the only villain and
that a lot of people might get rid of
the sugar but then continue eating
processed food or hummus with canola oil
or you know chips from the store that
are cooked in soybean oil and not stand
it and this could be driving a lot of
the disease that we're seeing in a
really subtle way some restaurants have
molded their entire business structure
around these cheap long lasting oils
even in and out the legendary Burger
chain in the west coast of America
proudly proclaims that their french
fries are only fried in 100 sunflower
oil and because the label says trans fat
free we think it's okay to eat at least
it's better than before right yeah well
these trans fat free oils actually might
be worse than their High trans fat
counterparts studies are coming out on
the dangerous chemicals created by trans
fat free oil that has been heated over
and over again in restaurant Friars
aldehydes one of the aldehydes is a
formal marker for your cancer for cancer
risk and aldehydes are created and are
just created in huge amounts in Fry when
they fry food in in polyunsaturated oils
restaurant owners are saying that this
oil is creating a strange gooey
substance that is impossible to clean
off their walls turns out that gooey
substance is actually a polymer he said
the polymers this these degraded
molecules were so unstable
that when they would put the uniforms in
the backs of trucks to go take them to
the cleaners the uniforms would
spontaneously combust
um and then when they took them to they
cleaned them and they put them in the
dryers there were still so many of these
toxic chemicals in them that they would
they would explode in the dryers
so I mean just imagine we're just all
putting this in our bodies once more
studies on the effects of these new oils
hit mainstream media Crisco Mozilla and
all the other vegetable oil brands will
probably have to adjust again whatever
they do we probably won't know about it
until three decades from now and by then
the damage will already have been done
foreign
to this day U.S dietary guidelines still
say that we should cope with Canola corn
and soybean oil that's right even after
all of this the edible oil industry
still has the faithful backing of the US
governments that is how powerful they
are and you want to know what else the
government shoves down our throats
fluoride you know Florida right it's in
your toothpaste tap water table saw
bottled water the government doesn't let
you escape it even if you wanted to why
because it's good for you they say it's
good for your teeth it prevents cavities
when in reality in reality floorway
started out as a harmful poison that was
part of the aluminum manufacturing
process in reality high doses of
fluoride have been found to lower IQ in
children among many other very bad
things and yet for some reason floorway
was able to go from this manufacturing
poison to something that's good for you
that we need to shove into your water
supply for some reason the United States
Canada Australia Ireland New Zealand and
the United Kingdom generously provide
you with fluoride air tap water free of
charge why click the card on the screen
to watch our new documentary on Florida
right now now on our new channel called
evil food supply I created this new
channel because I've been getting way
more serious about my health so this
channel will be a way for me to force
myself to study all the evils of our
modern diet so we all benefit
click the card to watch And subscribe
now
[Music]